and i really really enjoy acting
like on this little sitcom i've got i i
just wait i
i it's the best job i ever had call me
cat and mayam bialik is our
executive producer she's an actress on
it as well which
doubles the fun because she knows what
actors need to work
and here we are over an empty warner
brothers by the way right now is empty
you drive is so sad to drive onto an
empty not soundstage an empty
lot there's nobody there and then you
park in your little given spot
and you walk into an empty sound stage
the makeup people have shields right and
they have to wear
white jumpers and they make you up and
then they put you back
in your shield and everything and you're
put back in your room
but you sit in that dressing room
forever and then the
cameras get ready and there's nobody
there and we make comedy with no
laughter because see there's nobody that
our kind of show should have been
multi-cam
and should be shooting in front of an
audience and it'll be years i think
i really do think it will be years
before but an
audience and so there's no audience and
the you know the
the i tell the cameraman i'm laughs
class
and all you ever hear is the writer the
one writer over there that wrote that
joke
it's always that one guy it's always
that's it must be his episode that's his
episode that's his joke
is it hard for me he said to me one time
and then they add the laughter
i said to him they said you're taking a
beat here you don't need just go right
here cause here's the laugh
and i said no i feel this is the laugh
they go
the life is where we put it and we're
gonna put it there
oh my god
you